c'est une forêt dont l'oeil ne voit
jamais les limites où se cachent au
bouddha les interminables des châteaux
depuis le 19e siècle la sologne est
devenu le terrain de jeu des grandes
fortunes comme le baron bich
célèbre pour ses stylos et ses briquets
bas de gamme il préférait le haut de
gamme pour ses loisirs
à la fin des années 80 le baron a créé
sur son domaine de chasse deux parcours
de golf classé parmi les plus beaux du
monde selon les revues spécialisées où
se croisent des célébrités comme clint
eastwood ou hugh grant
aujourd'hui le golf international
déborde est réservé aux membres qui
peuvent s'offrir ce luxe la cotisation
annuelle varie de deux à six mille euros
selon les options mais il faut au
préalable s'acquitter d'un droit
d'entrée dont le montant est beaucoup
plus élevé
aujourd'hui on a à peu près un peu plus
de 150 membres et on
on laissera entraînement vraiment
progressivement pour avoir vraiment des
nationalités très diverses et pas
d'avoir par exemple que des français que
des anglais donc l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'avoir un golf international
et ensuite si je dirais que maximum 600
membres mais ça va vraiment dépendre des
nationalités si vous voulez ça dépend
des nationalités si par exemple on a
énormément d'étrangers ou et où plus de
français l'objectif c'est vraiment que
les membres puissent toujours jouer sans
sens qu'il ya énormément de monde en
toute tranquillité sans avoir du monde
derrière ou de monde devant
hors saison l'ambiance est on ne peut
plus tranquille sur les greens comme au
club house
sept jours sur sept toute l'année le
personnel est à disposition des membres
qui veulent passer un moment agréable au
coin du feu ou profiter du restaurant
est ce qu'on a comme activité plutôt
calme très calme très calme
en dehors
on a des clients qui arrivent ce soir
qui restent à l'hôtel pour plusieurs
nuits
dans quelques mois les golfeurs auront
le choix entre résider à l'hôtel ou
devenir propriétaires de maisons
individuelles en cours de construction
pour acquérir l'un des 90 cottage il
faudra débourser selon le modèle choisi
entre huit cent mille euros et 2
millions 8
et dans un autre secteur du domaine qui
s'étend sur 600 hectares un nouvel hôtel
doit voir le jour dans ce château avec
des perspectives d'emploi qui pourrait
amener le golf international des bords
de dans une autre dimension
aujourd'hui on est à peu près 50 cents
salariés en cdi répartis dans divers
divers domaines on a à peu près une
trentaine de jardiniers de golf des
serveurs restauration les métiers de
caddies masters tout ce qui est autour
du golf est alors le projet dans
l'avenir c'est à peu près six ans un peu
plus de 600 salariés donc c'est vraiment
important pour nous et c'est un vrai
challenge aujourd'hui
pour développer ce projet le fonds
d'investissement qui possède le golfe
s'est associé à une chaîne d'hôtels de
luxe à tirer elle aussi par l'image de
marque du territoire lorsque l'on à des
visiteurs surtout étrangers évidemment
on ne reste pas sur le site on les
emmène faire
voyez par exemple une remontée de loire
à saint dié sur loire sur les sur les
bateaux à fond plat on les emmène voir
les châteaux bien évidemment chambord
qu'était un quart d'heure c'est vraiment
une destination voilà la douceur de
vivre le val de loire et la sologne bien
sûr
la sologne plus attractif que jamais
kerry talon est bien placé pour le
savoir
agent immobilier à romorantin il est
spécialisé dans la vente des grandes
propriétés
il ya certains secteurs où
j'ai eu la chance devant deux trois ou
quatre propriétés qui sont pas loin les
unes des autres et quand je passe
souvent fait un tiens voilà faudra que
je vienne redire bon jour où je m'arrête
j'appelle juin boire un café
de mes préférés 7
dans son catalogue certains domaines se
négocie à plusieurs millions d'euros et
pour avoir une belle maison au calme
avec un grand et ans et au moins un
million qu'il faut investir c'est le
calme la quiétude quand tu te lèves le
matin tout fait voler ça doit être
magnifique
les vrais solognot qui possèdent ce
genre de propriété sont moins nombreux
que les parisiens ces textes chef
d'entreprise fait partie des exceptions
il a choisi de s'installer au pays pour
sa retraite j'ai cherché longtemps j'ai
cherché c'est difficile à trouver les
propriétés sont chers et c'est difficile
à trouver
mon ce genre de propriété avec étant à
côté de la maison l'a vu et où c'était
mon rêve et puis non la jules coup de
coeur j'ai le coup de coeur donc j'ai
vraiment dépenser tout ce que j'avais
pour pour l'acheter
c'est un marché qui est très tendue on a
beaucoup plus de demandes que de gens
qui veulent vendre le marché 500 700
milles on a une vraie pénurie parce que
dès qu'on vend un appartement à paris
les gens viennent avec cette somme juste
sur la vente d'un appartement ils
peuvent avoir une petite propriété en
sologne en reçoit pour de la chasse ou
soit pour du loisir de l'agrément
le marché des belles propriétés est
limité car les acheteurs les conserves
en moyenne 12 ans là des moyens de
s'installer dans le secteur et de
profiter du morcellement d'un grand
domaine à l'occasion d'une succession
avant on avait des gens
qui venait d'un certain niveau social
des gros chefs d'entreprises etc et
maintenant on arrive à accéder à la
propriété en sologne
des cadres ou des gens qui veulent
prendre leur retraite ça a évolué de ce
côté ci
des parisiens qui rêvent de sologne
thierry talons on appela son carnet
d'adressés quand il trouve ce qui
correspond à leurs critères ils doivent
réagir vite ce qu'a fait cet avocat en
retraite il ya quelques mois
pas trop près l'autoroute parce que pour
le bruit mais la proximité relative de
paris oui oui c'est à dire qu'on est à
deux heures de route de paris quand ça
roule bien
et à une heure et demie en train depuis
vierzon salbris donc c'était au c'était
aussi un critère un critère de choix
pour acquérir des bois qui font le
bonheur des chasseurs il faut compter
dix mille euros l'hectare et les prix
montent à 15000 euros pour un plan d'eau
[Musique]
des bécasses là il y en a oui une très
bon week-end les pigeons toujours
parlant toujours pas désert un désert
c'est les sangliers
s'il vous plaît
il va falloir faire quelque chose en
plein jour
là à 100 mètres de la maison des arts
la théorie du ruissellement qui
voudraient qu'une partie de l'argent
dépensé par les riches profitent ensuite
à tous est contestée par beaucoup
d'économistes mais en sologne certaines
entreprises comme les armureries
prospère grâce au bon plaisir d'une
clientèle des vite
hélas besoin de munitions elle a besoin
de vêtements pour s'habiller mais aussi
elle tombe en panne donc il faut réparer
et il faut réparer tout de suite parce
que le besoin est immédiat c'est la
chasse c'est pour le week-end donc
j'arrive le samedi je suis en panne il
faut que le dimanche matin je sois
équipe et voilà et puis d'autres besoin
c'est-à-dire
coup de coeur sur une arme que nous
avons en exposition ce que vous avez ici
c'est donc un fusil à platines pour vous
montrer la petite gravure qui est du
petit bouquet anglais
donc vous voyez c'est très fin et de me
ça demande beaucoup d'heures de travail
[Musique]
pour les plus beaux calibre d'une
prestigieuse marque anglaise il faut
compter et 15000 euros
ici le chasseur doit trouver tout ce qui
sera nécessaire ou superflus si besoin
sur mesure et l'activité se développe
les deux gérants viennent de recruter
une sixième salariés nous nous vivons
directement de l'activité chasse de par
notre métier mais
de par les gens qui ce se qui ont acheté
des propriétés en sologne
qui font vivre les artisans les
commerces de bouche
de par les gens qui viennent chasser en
sologne de l'extérieur.tous skier
hôtellerie restauration tous tous ces
métiers vivent des retombées de la
chasse les gens qui travaillent dans ses
propriétés en sologne pratiquement
chaque personne dans sa famille il ya
quelqu'un qui vit directement ou
indirectement de la chasse aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que auxerre qui traîne donc en
général lecerf lecerf il laisse pas les
gardes derrière donc la trace est
rond mais il n'y a pas les gardes alors
que le sanglier on voit les deux gardes
entre taux d'activité comme garde-chasse
christian bedrunes a appris à connaître
les comportements du gibier et les
attentes des propriétaires qui lui ont
confié la gestion de ce domaine de 140
hectares
les grecs tu
as les exigences et déjà que le
territoire soit entretenu très bien
entretenue qu'on puisse circuler après
les exigences du travail de garde c'est
à dire avant tout que la chasse soit
peuplé d'animaux et soyez
quilles un tableau en fin de journée les
chasse se déroule très bien
et pour savoir dans quel domaine on
trouve les plus grosse concentration
avant les week ends de chasse le garde
aujourd'hui assez technique la
vidéosurveillance n'est pas uniquement
en ville ou dans le métro il ya trois
quatre animaux sont pas des gros cerfs
c'est un appareil photo avec une
détection infrarouge et dès qu'il ya
quelque chose qui coupe le rayon
infrarouge il est pris en photo alors
que ça soye un animal renards sangliers
cerfs mais ça peut être aussi quelqu'un
de champignons ou quelqu'un qui se
baladent à
le garde observe le gibier mais il
incite en plus à rester sur des zones où
il est sûr de trouver de la nourriture
qu'on a préparé pour lui c'est ainsi que
dans ce secteur de l'ouest du loiret les
cerfs se déplace en troupeaux et les
sangliers prolifèrent
le bonheur des uns fait le malheur des
autres tant pis pour l'agriculteur qui
travaille sur la propriété voisine ici
l'espèce rare qu'il faudrait protéger
c'est le paysan dont les efforts sont
ruinés par les ravages du grand gibier
bah ça il faut là il faut le remettre en
état il ya des fois faut leur sommet
parce que si c'est bien massacrer comme
ça ben hilli adler et une partie de
l'ère pierre démarre pas ou de la
mauvaise herbe ou les chardons parce que
derrière les dégâts de sommier c'est
aussi des chardons qui redémarre souvent
sur les 27 ans passés
je peux facilement estimé à 180 milles
euros de de dégâts de ce cas de ce que
m'a coûté le grand gibier
dont trois ans jean marc vallée prendra
sa retraite et il sait déjà qu'il n'aura
pas de successeur les propriétaires des
terres qu'ils exploitent auront intérêt
à vendre à des chasseurs les prix ont
tellement augmenté ces dernières années
que les agriculteurs ne pourront pas
suivre
le paysan il a le droit de préemption
pour acheter pour pour cultiver mais
alors au prix où ça se vend ça se vend
plus cher qu'en beau ça on entend des
prix de 10 12 15 mille euros l'hectare
donc pour travailler la terre non c'est
pas la peine faut sauver 1 ça passe pas
partout en france des milliers
d'hectares de terres agricoles
disparaissent chaque année sous la
poussée de l'urbanisation mais en
sologne c'est là fort et qui gagne du
terrain sur les champs et les pâturages
en loir et cher on voit que la perte de
surfaces agricoles est beaucoup plus
marquée en sologne sur la zone en verre
à droite de la carte elle atteint 25 %
sur la période 2010 2018 c'est vrai que
quand on commence à se retrouver tout
seul ou qu'il ya deux ou trois dans ces
secteurs là et et avoir enfin moi je
sais que moi le premier si c'était à
refaire je me rase talent les paysans
oui mais alors surtout pas dans ces
zones là parce que sabo est un beau coin
et puis là pour le coup je suis sur une
ferme que tout est groupé en élevage
c'est le rêve mais non des dégâts de
gibier
on tente le coup parce qu'on sait pas où
on met les pieds mais moi ce sera à
refaire je le referais pas
[Musique]
en sologne le gibier se chassent à coups
de fusil mais c'est l'argent qui chasse
les agriculteurs
la disparition programmée de cette
espèce devenue gênante va modifier les
paysages
l'effacement des halls ouverte qu'ils
entretiennent aura un impact sur la
biodiversité
[Musique]